[ Indistinct conversations,
laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We're about to shoot a thing
with Jerry Seinfeld and Jimmy
where we have a huge
"Tonight Show" set
built completely out of LEGOs --
LEGO desk, LEGO buildings,
LEGO mugs.
Jimmy and Jerry are gonna do an
interview from the LEGO set,
and it's gonna be really funny.
-After talking to their team
and hearing about their process,
we needed to design
our set in LEGOs
in order to understand how to
design it in full scale.
All of these pieces that
you see are actual LEGO pieces,
just blown up, brick by brick.
So it has a lot of integrity,
LEGO-wise.
We made -- This could truly be
built this way in LEGOs.
-We have no feet here, right?
-Yeah.
-And now we have to
continue the show.
-Yeah.
-Right?
So I thought I would
help you get up on here.
Because what's funny with
these things is the feet up.
-It is.
-That's the funny part.
-Okay, good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well, you've got -- You have...
You got to roll over.
Then you'll sit up like that,
and I'll sit here
with my feet up.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh!
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-We have to use these.
-Oh, yeah.
This has to be a --
-Yeah.
-Maybe you take a sip,
not even talk about it,
and then, at one point,
I'll just take a sip.
-Yeah, and we don't even say --
-We don't say anything about it.
-Right.
-It's so funny.
-Oh, thank you, thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think what's funny is if
we just keep doing the show
as if -- and not even
talk about it.
-Yeah. And just what
you're saying,
just a normal thing.
-Yeah.
And then you're like, "Well...
You know, blah, blah, blah,
and just pour it.
-Yeah.
Why don't you learn
how to enunciate,
and maybe we don't have to do
this over and over again.
-Exactly correct.
-It's not always my fault,
you know.
[ Laughter ]
-Enough water.
Enough water for me.
-Then how do we get back?
-And then we hold hands,
and "There's no place like 6B."
-Yeah.
-"There's no place like 6B,
there's no place like 6B."
Then we go back.
And then we're back
to the studio and everything,
but I'm just at the desk
kind of daydreaming.
Alright, so, how do we get back?
-Uh, hold my hand.
Now just say,
"There's no place like 6B."
-"There's no place like 6B."
[ Beeping ]
-And that's why your spouse
is like a rescue pet.
Jimmy.
Jimmy, are you listening to me?
-Oh, yeah. No, sorry.
Just -- Never mind.
My thanks to Jerry Seinfeld,
everybody.
All episodes of "Seinfeld"
are available on Netflix now.
Stick around!
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show"!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]